DEMOCRATS HAD BEFORE THE
MID-TERMS.
JOE MANCHIN NOT READY TO FOLLOW
ARIZONA SENATOR KYRSTEN SINEMA.
HE IS LEAVING THE DOOR OPEN
APPARENTLY.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU GET MORE
INDEPENDENT THAN I AM.
I LOOK AT ALL THE THINGS AND
ALWAYS LOOKED AT ALL THESE
THINGS.
I HAVE NO INTENTION OF DOING
ANYTHING RIGHT NOW.
WHETHER I DO SOMETHING LATER I
CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT THE FUTURE
IS GOING TO BRING.
KARL ROVE HAS A THEORY ON THAT.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
IS HE GOING TO DO THE SAME THING
OR WILL HE STILL CAUCUS WITH
DEMOCRATS EVEN IF HE WERE TO DO
THAT?
>> HE WOULD STILL CAUCUS WITH
DEMOCRATS.
FIRST OF ALL, BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN ARIZONA AND WEST
VIRGINIA.
IN ARIZONA, INDEPENDENTS CAN
VOTE IN ANY PRIMARY THEY WANT.
THEY CAN WALK INTO THE BOOTH ON
PRIMARY ELECTION DAY AND SAY I
WANT A DEMOCRAT BALLOT OR
REPUBLICAN BALLOT.
NOT SO IN WEST VIRGINIA.
WEST VIRGINIA ONLY REGISTERED
PARTISANS CAN VOTE IN THE
PRIMARY.
SO IN WEST VIRGINIA IF JOE
MANCHIN WANTS TO RUN AS AN
INDEDENT HE CAN'T RUN IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
SINEMA WILL SAY I'M SEEKING
RE-ELECTION AS A DEMOCRAT.
I AM AN INDEPENDENT.
SHE HAS A STRONG OPPONENT
ALREADY RUNNING IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY DIEGO.
NOBODY THINKING ABOUT RUNNING
AGAINST JOE MANCHIN.
TOO FEW DEMOCRATS IN WEST
VIRGINIA ANYMORE.
>> Dana: HE IS VULNERABLE IN HIS
RE-ELECTION AS A DEMOCRAT IN
WEST VIRGINIA?
I KNOW HE IS VERY POPULAR THERE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THIS IS A STATE THAT DONALD
TRUMP CARRIED BY, YOU KNOW, I
THINK 20 PLUS POINTS.
SO YEAH, HE IS IN TROUBLE IN A
GENERAL ELECTION IN WEST
VIRGINIA.
WHAT'S INTERESTING TO ME HE
COMMENTED ON THE TWO REPUBLICANS
ALREADY TALKING ABOUT RUNNING.
ONE A CONGRESSMAN WHOM HE SAID
IS JUST TRYING TO ADVANCE IN
POLITICS AND THE INCUMBENT
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR JIM JUSTICE
WHO HE SAID IF HE RAN AGAINST ME
HE WOULD BE RUNNING BECAUSE HE
WANTED TO DO THE RIGHT THING FOR
WEST VIRGINIA.
AN INTERESTING OBSERVATION.
ALREADY PICKING ONE CANDIDATE IN
THE REPUBLICAN PRIMARY TO OPPOSE
HIM.
>> Bill: WE MENTIONED THE FINAL
RACE IS IN THE FOR THE HOUSE.
WE FOUND THE STUDY ABOUT YOUNGER
VOTERS VOTING LESS FOR
DEMOCRATS.
I WILL SHOW YOU.
YOU HAVE A WHITE BOARD.
FOR 2022, 53% OF THOSE AMERICANS
AGE 30 AND UNDER NATIONWIDE
VOTED FOR THE DEMOCRATIC HOUSE
CANDIDATE.
COMPARE IT TO TWO YEARS PRIOR
WHERE IT WAS 61% WITH JOE BIDEN
AND 2018, 64% FOR DEMOCRATS.
THE TREND IS NOT THEIR FRIEND.
WHAT DO YOU SEE IN THIS, KARL?
>> WELL, MY WHITE BOARD PUT IT
MORE ELOQUENTLY.
I STARTED WITH 2018 AND WORKED
MY WAY TO 2020.
11-POINT DROP AMONG THE
DEMOCRATS FOR SUPPORT AMONG
UNDER 30-YEAR-OLD VOTERS.
7% INCREASE FOR REPUBLICANS.
REMEMBER, ONE OF THE THINGS THE
WHITE HOUSE STAFF WENT OUT AND
TOLD THE PRESS AFTER THE
PRESIDENT DECIDED HE WAS GOING
TO WIPE OUT HALF A TRILLION IN
STUDENT LOAN DEBT WITHOUT ANY
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO DO
SPECIFICALLY THAT WAS THAT THEY
WOULD INCREASE THEIR SUPPORT
AMONG YOUNG VOTERS IN THE
NOVEMBER ELECTION.
I THOUGHT IT WAS POLITICALLY
CRASS.
WE'LL TAKE A HALF TRILLION
DOLLARS OF TAXPAYER MONEY TO TRY
TO BUY BIGGER TURNOUT AMONG
YOUNG VOTERS.
IT DIDN'T WORK.
THEY DROPPED OVER TWO YEARS AGO
IN THE PRESIDENTIAL RACE.
THEY DROPPED BY EIGHT AND THE
REPUBLICANS PICKED UP BY FIVE.
OVER THE FOUR-YEAR PERIOD DOWN
11 FOR DEMOCRATS, UP SEVEN FOR
REPUBLICANS.
NOT A GOOD TREND LINE FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC SO-CALLED EMERGING
MAJORITY.
>> Dana: BUT THEN IF YOU PUT
THIS -- LET'S FAST FORWARD TWO
YEARS IN A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
THEN DO YOU EXPECT THAT TO HOLD
OR DEMOCRATS CONTINUE TO TRY TO
-- DEMOCRATS WINNING THAT VOTE?
>> I WOULD THINK THEY WOULD WIN
IT.
THE QUESTION IS THE MARGIN.
WHETHER OR NOT THE TREND
CONTINUES DEPENDS UPON WHO THE
DEMOCRATS NOMINATE AND WHO THE
REPUBLICANS NOMINATE.
IF THEY NOMINATE JOE BIDEN PART
OF THE PROBLEM IS YOUNGER VOTERS
UNDER THE AGE OF 30 SAY WHY DO
WE HAVE SOMEBODY WHO WILL BE 82
IF HE GETS REELECTED AND 86 AT
THE END OF HIS TERM?
IF THE REPUBLICANS NOMINATE
SOMEBODY YOUNGER, YOUNGER VOTERS
MAY SAY I THINK THAT PERSON
MAYBE THEY DON'T SHARE EVERY
VIEW I HAVE BUT I THINK THEY'RE
UP TO THE JOB AND FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH HAVING SOMEBODY
YOUNGER.
WE'VE BEEN THROUGH THIS DRAMA
BEFORE.
IN 1959 AND 1960 WE HAD A
PRESIDENT IN THE FORM OF
EISENHOWER.
TWO YOUNG MEN IN THEIR 40s
STEPPED FORWARD, JOHN F.
KENNEDY, RICHARD NIXON ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE.
PEOPLE WANTED A CHANGE FROM ONE
GENERATION TO ANOTHER.
>> Bill: THANK YOU, KARL.
>> Dana: INTERESTING.
ALWAYS A GOOD REMINDER OF
HISTOR